guarantee you he will kick sideways and
he will come after you yeah
um and so and you're going to have to
stand up to that kick back when I'm
kicked I kick back and what will your
argument against him
well let's wait and see if he's got a
criticism first Trump brutally
criticized her last week remember he he
said she was such a terrible Governor
that he made her Ambassador as a favor
to the people of South Carolina to get
her out of the state he posted quote on
a truth through social the greatest
thing Nikki Haley did for our country in
the great state of South Carolina was
accepting the position of U.N Ambassador
so that the incredible then Lieutenant
Governor Henry McMaster could be
governor of South Carolina where he has
done an absolutely fantastic job that
was a big reason why I appointed Nikki
to the position it was a favor to the
people I love in South Carolina hard to
find a more serious criticism than that